okay thank you very much um
i'd like to welcome everyone to today's
meeting of the governance and audit
committee
um that's both those who are
participating
and to those who are watching at home um
i run for a few housekeeping
points before we start and if you have
any technical difficulties
during the meeting then please contact
the democratic services officer on call
or attempt to assist you today's officer
on call is charles
and the number is five seven seven one
eight
six and i believe that'll appear in the
chat
box um i would ask participants when you
are not speaking
please mute your microphone this
minimizes background
noise and will help everyone to listen
to the proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted
permission to speak and to gain my
permission to speak
please very briefly indicate on the chat
on the right hand side of the screen
and i will then make a note and go back
to you once the person speaking is
finished
with everyone pleasant present please
ensure that their mobile phones are
turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls while the meeting is
in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
and ensure that you are in a quiet room
free from distractions for the
duration of the meeting please note this
meeting is being live streamed for
members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will be subsequently broadcast on the
all internet please can i ask members of
the committee to confirm
they are present in the meeting when i
read out your name
i will ask for the attendance of those
councillors who are participating
in order to speak under council
procedure rule
separately so i'll run through the list
um counselor dexter
i can see you there sorry mr chairman
i'm here hello there all right
councillor boyd
thank you um councillor crittenden
present chair thank you councillor curry
here chair thanks councillor duckworth
hey chair councillor pat moore
now i can't see councillor moore
um councillor shrub here chair
thank you and councillor towning
president president chair thank you
um i've not received any request for
from other councils to speak under 20.1
but are there any members here
who would like to speak under 20.1
no okay thank you so we move on to
apologies for absence um and i've had
apologies
from councillor cup councillor braidwood
and council of pew for whom councillor
vatigan is a substitute
um councillor atigan are you you're here
you just confirm good afternoon good
afternoon cheryl i'm here
thank you very much um are there any
other apologies
at all yes chair apologies received from
councillor pat moore thank you thank you
very much
okay so we move on to the next item two
which is declarations of interest are
there any declarations of interest from
anybody here
no okay thank you
item three is minutes of previous
meeting
and there are in fact two previous
meeting minutes to approve here
they proved the minutes of the meetings
have on the 25th of november
and the 10th of february copies which
were attached to the
um agenda pack um
so i'm i'm going to propose um
acceptance of those
minutes could i ask um councillor dexter
to second them please
i'll second mr chair thank you um
and unless i hear any objection i'll
take those as approved
so there's no objection thank you
so the item four is the quarterly
internal audit update
report and i'm going to ask
mr webb to introduce this report please
thank you chair good evening members
this is our regular quarterly internal
audit update report which summarizes the
work
undertaken by the east kennedy
partnership on your behalf
in the last quarter together with the
performance of the team
up to the 31st of december 2020
if i could draw your attention to the
table on page 15
that summarizes the nine new pieces of
audit work
undertaken during this quarter we were
pleased to
conclude substantial assurance in five
areas
they were housing benefits subsidy and
housing benefit over payments both of
which are
um administered on your behalf by eks
and civica
we also even concluded substantial
assurance in the areas of external
funding protocol
members allowances and expenses and
disabled facility grants
two areas where we concluded reasonable
assurance were
the kovit 19 discretionary grant scheme
the administration of that
and also cemeteries and crematoria
the last two pieces of work undertaken
in the last quarter weren't assurance
species of work
one was the housing benefit quarterly
testing for quarters one and 2
of 2021 where we sample
um housing benefit home transactions to
ensure that they are being processed
correctly
and also a data match
to identify any potential areas of fraud
in the business grants administered by
the council
in respect of kovic 19.
an important part of internal audit work
is follow-up
approximately three to six months after
the conclusion of each new
audio assignment we go back and
undertake a follow-up to ensure that the
recommendations that have been agreed by
management have been implemented
and details of those follow-ups
undertaken in the last quarter
are detailed in the table on page 25
of the agenda we undertook two
follow-ups during this period
um both of them the original assurance
level was reasonable
and the revised assurance level was
reasonable as well
the areas under review were the member
code of conduct and standards
arrangements
and also absence management of staff
which is administered on the council's
behalf
by the escape hr partnership
attached to the report on page 28
onwards
is annex 1 which shows progress against
uh the agree 2021
audit plan up to the 31st of december
we've got a slight um muddle with um
okay annex
two and three unfortunately they're the
wrong way around on the agenda pack
apologies
for that members um
on page 30 um page 32
we actually have a sorry appendix 3
which
um it would be a summary of any critical
or high priority recommendations
still outstanding at the time of
follow-up there's none to report this
quarter
as all have been implemented
appendix 2 is the definition of the
audio assurance statements i mentioned
earlier that
five of the audience had concluded
substantial assurance
and two reasonable assurance in terms of
what that means
that's defined uh for you in appendix ii
and actually we use the cipco
recommended assurance and statement
definitions
we also have definitions of the priority
for recommendations
critical high medium and low that's on
page 33 of your agenda pack
on page 35 we have
appendix 4 a list of those areas
where we still need to go back and
follow up where the assurance level at
the time of the original
audit was either limited or nailed
that is to keep those items on your
radar
um to let you know that we will be going
back to follow them up in due course
your final appendix uh which is appendix
5 and that's on pages 36 and 37 that's a
balanced score card of performance
indicators for the
scan audio partnership team
for example on page 36
we have chargeable days as a percentage
of plan days
which shows you what percentage of the
agreed plan
we have delivered up to the 31st of
december
there's also indicators in there in
terms of the cost per audit day
the amount of follow-ups we've
undertaken we issue
a client satisfaction questionnaire at
the end of each audit
and on page 37 you can see details
of the feedback from clients which is
always
very encouraging and also um performance
indicators surrounding the
qualifications of staff
and also cpd for members of staff
that concludes my presentation chair
obviously very happy to take
any questions that members may have on
the report
thank you okay thank you thank you very
much for that
um i don't see anybody um
asking to raise any questions um in the
chat
i i did have one quick one myself
if i may which is about the items in
appendix 4
that um were outstanding um
including the street cleansing building
control
and planning apps incoming section 106
agreements
um you mentioned that they they'll be
completed in
due course can you just confirm
if that that due course is quite early
in the new year
thank you chair yes all three that you
mentioned are
currently working progress so they
should be completed in time to report to
the next meeting of this committee
which if memory serves me correctly is
in july
okay thank you thank you very much um
so i'll ask you that question i had a
couple of members who do want to ask a
question i'll start with
you councillor duckworth first
hey uh thanks very much simon for that
presentation um yeah
on page 25 i just wondered with the
absence management has that changed at
all because of covert
19 and obviously has it impacted
the the way absence management is uh
recorded
it hasn't materially changed the
systems and processes other than
that um eastgamehr do actively
monitor details of any staff that are
testing positive
and for kovid19 or who are
self-isolating
as a result of that but other than that
um processes referrals to occupational
health
things of that nature haven't really
changed as a result of the pandemic
pandemic
um i hope that answers your question
counselor
i love you thanks very much okay thank
you
um and also a question from councillor
towning
yeah thank you simon for the
presentation uh just just reading
through the paperwork that i was um
and looking at future uh audits that are
going to be carried out
um i note that you you're going to carry
out the major
audit coming up uh rather than the
external auditor
uh are you going to also invite the
external auditor to
join in and give their brief on
on the on on the audit as well
thank you
we certainly liaise with um the external
auditors grant thornton um
in terms of ensuring that there is
synergy between
our work and theirs um to avoid overlap
um and also um to ensure that they
can place reliance upon our work i'm not
sure if that answers your question
counsellor
um or if i could add anything further
referring to the audit plan for next
year
which is a later item on the agenda yes
remember the current year's audience
yeah not talking about the um the uh
audit plan for
for next year yeah that's that's the
that's the next item i think on the
agenda
yes okay fair enough that's current
that's correct
uh tim that's correct we'll
we'll um we'll we'll rate that again on
the next item yeah
okay thank you okay thank you so
unless anyone else has got any questions
which i can't see
the recommendation here is that the
report is received
by um by members of the committee um and
i'll
propose that uh that it is an ask
councillor
dexter if he wouldn't mind second in it
please if you can
yeah i'll second that motion mr chairman
thank you
so unless anyone objects to that i shall
take that as approved
thank you very much so item five
on the in on the agenda is the much
anticipated
draft internal audit plan um
and i'd like to ask ms parker to
introduce that please
thank you thank you good evening members
um in accordance with the best practice
uh the governance and nordic committee
should review and assess
the internal audit work plan for the
fourth coming year
so the purpose of this report is to help
the community through that process
and to fulfill your responsibilities in
terms of looking at that work
plan if i could take you
um to page 4142
of the agenda pack um the process this
is a draft plan for your input and
comment
um but there's a fair process that's
already been undertaken
to get it to the stage that it is
presented to you this evening um
internal audit has of course its own
risk assessment process well it will
have looked at past history what it
knows about
the system and the authority they will
have looked at
the corporate risk register who looked
at service plans and service risks in
terms of opportunities
and threats for each system to achieve
its objectives
the heads of services that direct us
are then we have meetings with them to
go through any new legislation any new
systems any big significant changes in
personnel
that they're aware of that may change
that risk profile
and consultation then through to
management team internal audit is a
section 151
responsibility this is some of the joke
and you'll hear quite regularly with
with in connection with internal audit
and of course it is
the section 151 officer's plan
and he must assure himself and that
under legislation that there are
resources in place to be able to provide
assurance on the key risks leading all
through to the year end when we come to
form our opinion
um so so this all the glue that holds
this
together so on um a part of that
risk assessment process i was describing
is not only to look inwards
at panic district council but also to
look at the horizon
um in other sectors as well as local
government
so the top 10 risks as identified really
through my profession the institute of
internal auditors are listed for you in
section 2.3
and for each of these risks in turn
we've considered the risk
we have looked at whether we need to
make a provision in this year
or in a future year um given uh what we
know and what we've discussed with with
officers
there's quite a bit of detail there i
won't go through each in turn but
uh clearly just want you to be aware of
of the process
of course there are insufficient
internal audit resources to review
all areas of activity in each year and
the plan then
forms its risk assessment to look at
those those operations
and there's a cycle of audits and behind
that
and and the plan before you this evening
uh covers
multiple years we're only asking members
to seek approval for the forthcoming 12
months work plan
the other years are there to indicate
that there could be there is a rolling
cycle
to give you assurance over that period
taking you through to 3.1 in the report
i think it's important that members
are aware of uh the level of audit
provision against the benchmark
um whilst we've only really kept up our
benchmarking within
kent the average of 400 days and it
compares well
against the average which takes me to
paragraph
four where i commend the draft plan to
you this evening
and the recommendation members is for
approval
of the plan and the plan itself is set
out on pages 47-52
so we're happy to take any questions
thank you
thank you thank you for that um well i
can't see any questions although i think
maybe um we could go back to the
question
asked by um councillor towning i don't
know if
cancer town and you want to um recap
on what your question was about um
about the review yes
thank you thank you christine um
obviously obviously previously the
external auditor used to carry out um
the the the audience right across the
board
um and you used to do your own internal
audit separately
uh what is the thinking behind the new
plan
uh why are we uh you're do
i have no objection to you doing it
don't get me wrong but
i want to know how much involvement the
external auditor will have to
and have have a base to actually input
stuff into your audit
because they obviously know and find
other things out
regarding the governance and and so
forth and uh
how would that work
thank you for the question um my
colleague indicated
a level of liaison in fact you'll see a
line in the plan
for an amount of time to liaise with the
external auditor
the purpose um of our liaison is to
ensure that we're not duplicating any
effort
um we would also seek to place assurance
on other
assurance providers for example you
might have work undertaken for the
council by the food standards agency
and that would be a year that we might
seek not to look at food safety but
place reliance on their work
i did actually intend to say in my
presentation so apologies members that
this this is a plan
and as with all plans and i think uh
2020 21 is
is a good example we we do need to flex
and bend
uh and change the plan and members will
see in in the the item before the
quarterly update report that changes to
the plan are something that we
we do regularly expect you know things
happen through the year a higher
priority piece of work may crop up and
we're asked to push something back
in its place and with the
council obviously taking in the east
kent housing
responsibilities and forming its new
housing service
we have obviously made provision for
those areas and it's possible that as
the year
unfolds we might be asked to do more
work there at the cost of
of the planned work so that kind of um
flex is to be expected to some extent it
is a plan based on what we know
now um i think councillors um
you will see from my risk assessment um
in terms of the risks in terms of like
for example digital cloud computing
the new home working the the the new
risks that the council has faced in
terms of
responding to the you know unprecedented
changes in last year
um some of those things we've considered
and some of those things with
for example like number six disaster and
crisis management we think you've
probably tested your
business continuity plans to the to the
fullest extent
so some things are built in and some
things we're saying we'll delay that
i think members are probably also
interested in risk number 10.
conduct and culture risks that go across
the sector there have been
high-profile national sector headline
grabbing news
and these are it is an area that my
profession
is particularly interested in developing
in terms of ethics
and what we are asked to do by my
profession
is to look at the annual
corporate governance arrangements so
typically we would
break those down and you'll see in the
plan that we have provisions for
um anti-fraud and corruption
whistleblowing ethics codes and conduct
gifts and hospitality
officers code members code standards
arrangements
so in fact there's a report in the
quarterly update report on
on members and standards arrangements so
a lot of these
reviews aren't new what we have proposed
uh was to look at this in the whole um
and in the consultation with management
on this the management have suggested
that they approach external audit to
undertake this review
um upgrading the independence and part
of the work that they
plan to undertake so i think
hopefully that answers your question
we're not intending to duplicate
anything
external audit are planning to undertake
we've identified the risks we've said
why it's not in our plan
and we've obviously made the hook or
pointed to the fact that it's going to
be
in another plan ultimately this
committee
will need to seek assurance on those
risks
and you will need to be satisfied that
the assurance that you've had
enables you to sign off next year's
opinion and that's that's really
your terms of reference does that help
it certainly does thank you very full
answer thank you i appreciate that
yes thank you for that and um you you
mentioned um
that some of the some of this work that
you might have been asked to do
or might said you were doing it's
actually going to be done
by the external auditor and maybe when
we get to the
the piece on the agenda where the
external order
presents we can go into a bit more
detail about what that piece of work
is going to be and how it's going to be
done that would be very helpful
then okay but thank you um so i've got
there are a
couple of other questions from
from members um councillor duckworth
please thank you for the uh report
christine
uh yeah i just wanted to chat i don't
know if this actually is a question for
you
or uh one of the offices but um anyway
um
on page 40 the sector equality duty
there's nothing ticked on there and it
says that there are no equality issues
which
um obviously they are important because
they're mentioned in
0.5 on page 42 so should something be
ticked in that box to say that
it's relevant
thank you i think individually our
individual
audience don't ordinarily um lead us to
tick that box
um i think i would probably have to take
advice as to whether
that is the case when we're presenting
the plan um
so apologies if that's an oversight but
i think collectively tonight we're
approving a plan of work which isn't
uniquely linked to that um
yeah okay thank you
sorry and thank you councillor boyd
please
thank you chair um christine thank you
for your report
it was more of a comment as opposed to a
question and probably more of
consideration actually
um is it worth bringing
forward the planned
audits for areas such as information
management so data protection which
previously had limited
assurance and then again cloud computing
digital which is a new area hasn't been
um assessed
yet and i think it's because
we have made this shift into more
homeworking
more digital online services and is it
more of a risk that we
we're going to wait potentially wait
until
24 25 um to look at that
um and you know potentially we could
safeguard ourselves
sooner by bringing it forward a little
bit more and similarly
um project management um was
limited back in 2016-17 and presumably
the government
will and continue to give sort of small
pots of money here and there
specifically for projects
are we again putting ourselves at risk
if we aren't
um looking at those a bit sooner
um and therefore waste not potentially
wasting money but
not being as efficient as we could do
with project management
[Music]
thank you um so in taking your points in
turn the
information management the data
protection is a piece of work that we're
uh is working progress we're trying to
complete this year which uh will mean
what
that um it's projected to come into the
plan
later so hopefully that you'll they'll
see a piece of work coming through on
that one
um i'm not exactly sure what's happened
on the um
plan that's been presented to mount to
the um
committee papers the provision for 10
days
for cloud computing and digital should
be there
we had assessed that as being one that
needed to be done
this year and the and that was
effectively
in exchange for the 10 days that's
against the governance and culture
review
that was an update at the last um
iteration of the plan
uh so apologies members the ten days at
the top of page 48
should be at the bottom of page 47.
perhaps we can note that um or the
approval of the plan
also yeah
and project management um yes is in for
quarter three
of the new year
okay thank you um and on on that note
i've
seen uh mr willis did you wanna
thanks thank you um
i was a little bit confused about
how the plan was being presented it
differed slightly from the version
that i received when i gave my financial
implications comments
um i think when i saw the report the
governance and cultural review made
reference to the external auditor
but the one in front of us now doesn't
but it also shows there's ten days
in quarter one but christine parker's
just indicated that that's
incorrect so i'm a little confused um
what i would say is i do think that the
cloud issue is important
and it's one of those that you could put
off because it's such a moving target
and you could put it off until the end
of the year or you could do it
um at the start of the year and i think
now is as good as time as evie
for the reasons the council of boys is
highlighted um
on the governance and culture review i'd
i suggest that um the committee um and
as christine parker's highlighted this
is
in part my recommendation to you this
report
that there may be discussions between
external and internal audit in respect
of governance and culture
an external audit would consider
including it
in its own audit plan for the annual
accounts
of the annual audits but
this is an audit plan for internal audit
that we have before us
so i'd suggest that the committee
take a view on when it wants a
governance and culture review
without being too bothered about who
carries it out if you want it carried
out
you need to be clear when you want it
carried out because that's what this
plan is all about
great thank you yeah thanks for that for
that clarification
um i mean i i i believe and i
and um um obviously anyway if any other
members want to comment but i think
when it's something that needs to be
prioritized
earlier rather than later in the in the
um
year so i i believe it would be
good to have it have it in to be done
started early rather than later in the
year
um unless if any of any other members
got anything
they might contradict me on that but if
not then i'll take it that that's
that's that's our position surely we
should uh actually look at a
a period during which we should actually
um request the order to be carried out
rather than just leave it hanging in the
air and we should actually
find a period that which suits the right
time of the year
rather than gets confused with any other
audits that may be
taking place at the same time yeah well
i think my
my suggestion is that it's um that it is
one of the first things that's done so
it's earned early in the year
is that able to so it would fit in with
how i think how the draft audit plan
appears
at the moment you know with the with the
10 days
is that understandable but it might
suggest
um and this is something that um
obviously we normally have bottomed all
this out with that
christine and i would have bottomed this
out in advance but because of the
the confusion on the on the appendix
the committee could say what quarter it
would like
the audit to be conducted in and
um because there are some links
to other matters before other committees
of this council it would be i would
suggest
wise to not start it next week or
on the first of april um but
for the committee to consider if it's
not done by quarter two
if you want it done early i'd say not
necessarily the first quarter
but certainly by the second quarter yeah
okay that
sounds sounds reasonable reasonable to
me
if it hasn't been started by quarter two
then we'll
we'll we'll want to know why sort of
thing
i can see councillor curry's got a
question
thanks chet yeah it was just something
that come to mind and regarding um
third-party risk regarding the
non-performance of
contractors i just wondered was there
any specific areas of concern
thank you thank you chair
i think um it is a risk that everybody's
aware of
um i think we've had more than one
contractor
failing its performance and that's a
different risk in terms of contract
management arrangements
but what we get are um to discover
as normality kind of starts to come back
into our
contracts and the way that contractors
are performing is whether they will
survive
um the implications of whether they've
had people furloughed and whether
they've been able to undertake the work
and get get things moving
once the restrictions are lifted even if
we were to do companies house checks
on all our suppliers as at today and
look at the last
filed accounts it doesn't give us any
certainty that uh you know their
financial
sustainability and that they will
continue to be able to perform so it is
raising that risk that we
we should be very very aware of our
key suppliers who if they were to fail
um you know how that would impact the
council's risks
you thank you so if there
are there if there aren't any other
questions
or comments from members i think um
we've we've we've discussed and proposed
uh
an amendment to the um
to the internal audit plan in that the
the
review of governance and culture goes
into quarter one
and then uh that's then reviewed in in
the next meeting as to
if it hasn't started then we'll get a
reason as to why
so that's an amended audit plan along
those lines
um so i'd like to propose that
um and can counselor destiny can you
second that
i'll second the motion mr chairman thank
you very much
um so unless i hear any objection i
shall take that as
approved
thank you okay so let's move on to
um item six
which is the corporate risk management
quarterly update
and i'll call on mr blundell to
introduce that
thank you chair good evening members so
this is the standard quarterly risk
management update report that we
bring to this committee on a regular
basis the contents of this report
highlight the
high priority corporate risks and
describe the arrangements in place to
manage and monitor them so section four
of the report
includes a table with these key risks in
them uh namely political
political stewardship kobit 19
cyber attack limited resources and
brexit
members will observe that there's been
no change to the risk scores
presented in comparison to the november
2020 report
however i should highlight the risk that
was relating to
ekh performance and transition that has
previously been reported to the
committee is no longer considered to be
a key risk
as such has been de-escalated and is no
longer being reported to the committee
but still very much still be monitored
and managed by officers
uh beyond this and section five is
narrative to explain
these key risks i've just highlighted
and in more detail
explain the measures that have been put
in place to manage them
members are asked to review this review
of the corporate risks and i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you um do any any members have any
questions at all
um i've and i've got one that i'd like
to ask about
um which relates to the
political stewardship risk and really
it's a clarification
of what exactly this is because i know
and i i know there has been discussion
about this a previous one
it's mentioned in there that um it's
it's around
um the fact that the council is under no
overall control
um but there's also a statement in there
about
ongoing issues that could have a
significant effect on the council
could you just sort of clarify for all
of our benefit
you know what exactly this risk does
encompass
thank you chair um if i may i'm not the
risk owner for
for this particular corporate risk and
um it was previously as i think you uh
you stated um tim how to cover the
software file so if i may
pass this over to uh miss culligan to
answer this
is that okay
yeah thanks chris um
[Laughter]
thanks um chair sorry could you
could you repeat the question i know it
was about the political stewardship
is it about the level of risk yeah it's
about the level of risk and exactly what
it
what it means because i know we've
obviously earlier been talking
discussion about the issue
the political the the fact that we're
there's no overall control yeah and i
think you may you mentioned
that it the report says uh because of
ongoing issues i mean i read this risk
to be purely about the
issue of political control and no
overall control
uh and so i would say it's simply
because
um you know we don't have a a majority
party leading you know so there is
always the risk of
you know certain difficulties in
decision making et cetera et cetera
although however
uh you know things seem to be relatively
stable
you know despite this and i think the
report refers to
um you know cross-party working and
efforts to make decision making you know
as smooth as possible etc etc
but i suppose in any in any council
where you do have overall
no overall control sorry there is a risk
there is an inherent risk because you
don't have
the stability that you would have if you
had you know a majority party
able to push through decisions etc etc
that's how i would explain it um
and i think it's as simple as that
really but um i hope i've
you know if i haven't really covered off
what you what you're asking about then
then please do say all right
i've understood your explanation yeah
it's pretty binary really
from what you're saying if we had a if
we had a party who did it was in overall
control
this wouldn't be a high risk but because
what you're saying is because we have
it's a low it's uh
we haven't sorry it's so high i guess um
i think mr willis
thank you chair i was just going to um
support what stale culligan was saying
i think um right now it is what she says
it's because there's a minority
administration and that presents risks
um but in practice so far we are still
functioning
as a council and functioning i think
pretty well
overall all things considered um
i think some people would have been
around a long time longer than me
actually
going back to the days before 2015 when
i think
political stewardship and issues with
political stewardship
would have involved bad relationships
between
members and members and members and
officers
i don't think that's the case now and i
don't think that's meant to be reflected
in this risk score
why i think it's fair to say that this
is related to the minority
administration
okay thank you very much that's been
clarified thank you
so if there's no other members with any
questions or comments this
quarterly update is for our approval so
i shall propose
that we approve that we'll um cancel the
decks to reduce
second that please yeah i'll second the
motion mr chairman
thank you so unless i hear any objection
i'll take that as
as approved so that's approved
thank you very much item seven on the
agenda
is the 2021-2022 accounting policies
and again this is for mr blundell to
introduce thank you chair yes me again
uh so this report
presents the council's accounting
policies to be used for the forthcoming
2021 2022 financial year
and also highlights the proposed changes
to the audit deadlines for this year's
20 20 21 accounts
uh so in terms of the actual accounting
policies that have been presented within
appendix one or annex one i apologize
um there's there are actually no
significant changes to report from
the accounting policies that are
included in the
2019 to 20 accounts however
we are reviewing housing debt uh
write-off policy
alongside income management that's under
current review at the moment and still
to be finalized so there may be
a subsequent amended amendment to that
policy but we bring that to the
committee's attention before
approving the 2021 accounts in a year's
time
um in terms of the audit deadline so the
existing accounts and audit regs require
us to
prepare draft accounts by the end of may
and that needs to be audited and
approved by the end of july
a recent review conducted by sir tony
redmond argued that these dates are
actually unrealistic and that the
deadline for audit and approval
of the final account should be returned
to the end of september
as it was prior to the introduction of
the current regs in 2015.
in response to this recommendation the
government is consulting
on extending the deadlines for audit and
approval
and also um it's expected that the draft
accounts will be have to be produced by
the first of august
so the government's proposal these
arrangements will be in place for two
years
and trialled for that period of time and
then they would review them at that
point
the consultation closed on the first of
march we're yet to hear a response but
we've been told it would be a light
touch consultation so we expect to hear
a response shortly
so in terms of this report members are
asked to approve the accounting policies
and also to note the change to the audit
deadlines i'm happy to take any
questions on this
i haven't i haven't had any any members
uh requesting to ask a question or
comment
so um we shall move on to
i'll propose the acceptance of those
policies
but uh councillor dexter would you um
second that
please yes i'll
um i'll second the motion mr chairman
thank you so unless there's any
objection to that
we'll we'll move on that's agreed we'll
move on to the next
um the next item on the agenda is the
automate the audit findings report and
just before we move on to
that you'll remember from our previous
meeting in november that
the next couple of items were deferred
for a couple of reasons
so just before we move on to that i
think mr blundell
just wants to um introduce the items
with an explanation
about a few things thank you chair yes
just as a
a brief summary uh before handing over
to sarah iron manga and she's her report
so
as you rightly said this report
alongside the accounts themselves and
the assurance statement report were defi
deferred
actually at the committee meeting in
november and this was due to
accounting issues in relation to
dreamland
that arose very late in the order and
unfortunately due to the timing
we weren't able to resolve those between
officers and the auditors
which meant the accounts actually
couldn't be signed off at that meeting
and therefore the audit findings report
couldn't be considered at that time
um through the passage of time these
issues have now been resolved and as
such we're able to bring the accounts
and the audit finding
report to this meeting for the
committee's consideration approval
um but i'll actually i will hand you
over now to mr willis so it's a bit of a
relay process
he'll just give you a bit more detail
around the actual accounting
for dreamland before we go into sarah's
report
thank you thank you thank you
thank you chair um don't worry anyone
i'm not going to give a
technical accounting explanation of the
transactions or anything
um it's just an attempt to try and in
simple terms explain
what's happened regarding dreamland in
relation to the accounts
so at the end of the year 2019-20 that
these accounts relate to
the sale of dreamland was uncertain and
the settlement of the compulsory
purchase order
the cpo compensation was the subject of
ongoing negotiations and legal
proceedings
when the final accounts were brought
before this committee in november the
way in which we reflected dreamland
in the accounts was uncertain so a
decision on the accounts was deferred
in essence the issues were what should
be the value
the valuation of dreamland as an asset
in our accounts
and secondly how much should we assume
we would have to pay
for the cpo compensation both of those
issues were addressed in december
we sold dreamland or at least sold the
park
and exchanged contracts from the car
park for a total of seven million pounds
and we reached settlement on the cpo
compensation
which placed a value for that
compensation of a total of four and a
half million
this figure fluctuated significantly
over time
based on the advice we were receiving
from our external lawyers
these matters have now been resolved and
we are able to place reliance
reliable values in the accounts the
council issued a
media release and a report on these
matters on our website
on the 22nd of february and the link can
be included in the minutes of this
meeting
if it would be helpful thank you
thank you miss phillis yes and yeah that
would be helpful
please if we could include that link um
yeah i think it's important
that we all um fully are able to fully
understand exactly
what's happened with dreamland thank you
so
so now we actually get to the the bones
of the
the item and um i'll hand over to
sarah iron manga thank you thank you
and and the introduction i was going to
make has just been uh
out evenly explained by uh by both chris
and
tim um so i think the the really
positive thing is that at this point we
are now in a position to be able to
issue our opinion on the statement of
accounts and if i can
turn you to our report um
just very briefly run you through in the
headlines page 81 just gives
a bit of a summary of that in
fairly technical language um we are
intending to
issue an unqualified opinion uh there is
something called an emphasis of matter
paragraphs that we will be issuing
um now this is a a very technical thing
i think the important thing for members
to note is that this is not a
qualification
uh what this does is say that at the
31st of march
2020 the um your valuers for both your
um your london buildings but also the
um property that is held within the
pension fund
they issued something called a material
uncertainty in their valuation
so because they did so you have put
something in your accounts to reflect
that
and then we put something on our audit
report which effectively draws attention
to the disclosure you've put there so
yes it's an unusual thing
um prior to um
march 20 these were fairly rare
um they are they are being issued on
every single
31st of march 2020 set of accounts so um
it's just to help you understand what
that issue is
um and i think the other one on the
headlines for page 82
the value for money conclusion we are
not giving that conclusion at this point
but we can go into the detail on that as
as we run through the report
so those are the headlines of where we
are um
i think if we run through our report we
pull through materiality we talk about
the different risks that we've looked at
um page 86 talks a bit more about
how you do your revaluation of your land
and buildings
and and then um and page 87
does a little bit more about the pension
liabilities and the impact
of the pension fund holding poor
property investments which again has
that material uncertainty on it
then page 88 for the next two or three
pages provides a little bit more detail
about that the dreamlands transaction um
and so what's essentially where we're
coming from
on this issue and we have agreed what
those figures are in the accounts
is that uh as at the 31st of march 2020
we think that the asset needs to be
classified as an asset health for sale
which
absolutely is what it is the
technicality of this is if you move
classifications it changes the base of
the value and that's where
that's where a lot of these transactions
happen so that's
that's more detail on that um and then
page 89
talks about the the impact on the cpo
and how that's been done um with page 90
sort of just showing that this appears
all over within the accounts there's
various elements of it
so it's um you know it is a complex
transaction
it is something that um is is somewhat
of an unusual transaction so therefore
required both the finance team and the
audit team to
to take that step back and really
understand what was going on there
so i think the rest of the the rest of
the report on those
um there are some other findings in
there but i think it's largely bringing
your attention to
to what has happened um and then i think
at the very end
although i won't take you there now is
there's a long list of adjustments that
have been made
um some of these relay obviously
transactions we've just spoken about
that is very complex
um but all of those have been made
so on page 99
we start on the of your packs we start
on the value for money
so in 2018-19 there were four objections
to the accounts
um that prevented the value from the
conclusion being issued
uh three of those are now resolved but
with one with one ongoing so the uh
money conclusion is not uh able to be
given for 1819 which therefore means we
cannot issue
the 1920 value for money conclusion
either
but didn't stop us doing any work on the
area there's a couple of items that we
have looked at
um but this work is ongoing and we will
keep members updated as we progress
so turning to what we have done on the
value for money
um page 100 we start talking about the
ongoing financial sustainability
members will be very uh very aware of
the impact covetous had
on your um the pressure it's put on your
financial position
this is um this is replicated up and
down the country all local authorities
have
have had real pressures from it what we
are saying
in this is we're looking at your
arrangements you have updated
uh your your position you have looked at
um what you can and you can't do and
what you can manage you
you have been able to use reserves
uh in 2021 to mitigate the in your
financial position
and that is um that is a perfectly
acceptable thing to do in the short term
but what we're saying is that's not
something you can continue to do
um we are we are giving these messages
everywhere i think when we turn to page
101 you see that what we're saying is
you've got
a significant challenge i know members
are aware of this
you have got a challenging financial
savings plan
um in place um to meet the budget gaps
going forward
and and it's really just highlighting to
you
yes you've got those things in place but
you really need to make sure that you
you as a council are meeting those um
the plans you put in place to save
because
uh you need to be in a position to be
able to replenish those reserves
um and it's it's a difficult position
and
our message is really you've got to keep
a focus on it
um there's another piece on page 101
where we talk about governance
arrangements which i know members
had a discussion earlier an internal
audit plan
so there are some matters that uh we are
considering
um where we have not been able to reach
a conclusion because there are is
another process running
uh which needs to uh come to a
conclusion
where we have reached a position on is
that we're going to
uh specify what's like the terms of
reference of what we're going to look at
so that we can be very clear about what
we can look at that does not
uh impact on the parallel process that
is running and what we need what needs
to wait
until a later stage and then that will
give the clarity
of what we can look at at this point in
governance and what we can't look at
so that's that's what the going forward
piece is
and then on page 102
we bring up our we bring back in the
conversation that we've been having
about east kent homes
um i know that these matters have been
reported to members
before and we give a summary of what's
happened there
and we do recognize that um that the
council took
uh action promptly when these issues
were brought to your attention
but what we are saying is that actually
during 2018-19
because of the issues that were there
the arrangements
um were not um were not sufficiently
robust
in 2018-19 um but i think because you've
taken prompt action you've brought the
service back in-house that has
progressed your arrangements forward
so that is um i think the only thing
really left that i will point out
is the high recommendations um on page
105.
so the particular one on savings
identification i spoke about
um and and management and management
puts a response in there and then the
second one on accounting for complex
transactions
so it is um you know whilst we would all
hope that um
uh these complex transactions are
are rare um it's just a point around
that and then the rest of the action
plan has some
some other items that came up during the
audit with responses from management
i will pause that and take questions
[Music]
thank you thank you very much for that
um
so if there's anybody got any questions
then please do
let me know i haven't seen anyone asking
any questions
i just maybe if i ask a question or two
um other members might might think of
one or two themselves
um so you mentioned on uh
around the monitoring of savings that
and the criticality of that i mean how
how closely are you in fact
involved in monitoring that and and
making sure that that's happening to
your satisfaction
okay so i think the first step is that
as
as the council it's um it's your role to
identify those and to agree what those
savings plans are
management will be reporting back to you
on the achievement of those and i think
our point
what what our responsibility is is to
review the arrangements you have in
place
to manage that so therefore we will be
looking at
um the reports that come to you we'll
probably be
uh we'll be talking to the finance team
going forward
as to where that progress is what what
is happening
within it and that falls within our
value for money process
um i think the point we're making about
your arrangements is it's really
important that members are clear on
where that progress is um and
and not to with the all the other issues
that um a council like
thanex has to manage it's not forgotten
in all of that
um there's nothing you know we're not
saying at the moment that we've got any
concerns about the arrangements
um but you know mr willis may want to to
come in here and explain a bit more
about the arrangements you've got
i believe he does yes mr willis
thank you chair thanks sarah um i don't
want to go through the
financial management arrangements we
have in place um rather
i just wanted to point out that
probably members are bored with me
constantly saying that we
have very low reserves and we have
little resilience but we're doing the
best we can
and we need to do what we say we're
going to do and
and not do what we say we're not going
to do
um and i know every year the external
audience says that you have
very challenging medium-term financial
strategy there's lots of savings to
deliver and it's going to be difficult
i agree wholeheartedly with that view
from the external audit
on the on the other hand i would say if
you look at
um other outcomes
sit for releases a financial resilience
index every year
which sort of does a collection across
all the country
as to how financially resilient each
local authority is
it's true if you look at that you will
find that than it
has low levels of reserves relative to
other districts
local locally as well as nationally and
that has
always been the case ever since i've
been here in the last six years
um what it does also show though is that
year on year we're improving our
position um now kovid will have had an
impact on that as it will have done on
all local authorities but up to
1920 it shows that year one year we've
improved our level of reserves
improved our level of reserves against
our net revenue expenditure
and we've actually also improved our
balance sheet position
we've paid down debts and we've improved
our level of equity
so we're edging in the right direction
albeit very slowly and albeit with an
under
underlying low level of reserves which
is a constant
financial risk and challenge to us
okay thank you thanks for that
explanation because i asked
how closely are you monitoring these
sort of things i guess
i should say it's it's incumbent on us
members to be involved fully involved in
these decisions and discussions as well
and do that yeah yeah and i think um i
think just to sort of amplify
what tim said is so the conversations
that tim and i have is uh
is actually you know how how resilient
are you if there's another
shock to the sort of financial position
of local authorities and it's it's
that piece you need to be really
continue to be really alert to
yeah okay thank you okay i do have a
question now from
councillor towney
hi sarah i'm going to start with um
where tim has left off that that was
going to be my last question actually to
you but i've got other questions i want
to raise
okay um in your report you talk about
unsustainable um levels of reserve
i mean what would you call an
unsustainable res uh
in a level of reserve the other thing is
this that
you also point out that uh during the
period of 2223
uh that we're going to start to
replenish our reserves
now i i appreciate what you're saying
but
i mean what evidence has you know i mean
tim
and chris do a phenomenal job for the
council
uh what evidence have you got to base
that
uh that statement on
uh you know can you just explain those
two points firstly to me
okay on page 101 what i'm saying
is um you have used reserves um
to meet the pressures that have come
from kovid and we are not we're not in
any way criticizing you
for that what we are saying that is if
you repeated
that and you repeatedly rely on reserves
without taking action to address the
underlying budget position
then that leads to the risk the either
reserve levels become unsustainable
or you have to take rapid service cuts
to maintain a sustainable position
we're not saying that's the position
you're in we're saying that
that is the risk if if you if you
continue
to need to go into reserves to support
your position
so we're not saying you've done that
we're saying there's a there's a risk if
you
if you went down that route
okay thanks did you have it
and and what i mean what evidence do you
have to
to actually establish that we will be in
a position
22 23 to replenish our
of the reserves that we've dipped into
to balance our
our budget i mean what has the council
provided you with
um so we have looked at the medium-term
financial strategy
and we've had conversations with both
tim and chris on that um
to to reach that that's that's what your
plans currently are saying
okay thank you just for come back to you
council town i think
tim willis wanted to say something yes
thank you chair and uh this is often the
case that members at governance nordic
comment
on the auditor's findings on our
medium-term financial strategy and
actually it makes me think that chris
and i should consider
bringing the draft medium-term financial
strategy to governance nordic committee
in future years
because i think it is a it provides a
better context
what i would say is that we do have
an objective to increase reserves to
start replenishing reserves
from um the year after next i think it
is
um and i would also say that in a
strange way we sort of
have already started it because um
during the year
we were hit by kovid and we realized
that we would have a big hit a big
one-off hit
it's not to say that there isn't an
ongoing impact of kovid over
a number of years but certainly back in
the summer
it was a one-off hit and we estimated
that was gonna cost us three million
pounds
so we went to count cabinet and then we
went to council
and council agreed to find that three
million pounds of reserves
to fund the the overspend caused by
kovid19
and i thought that was a very important
moment for the council to recognize that
it had to make tough decisions
in year to deal with those sorts of
problems
i think as time passed we've now begun
to realize that
the government has provided emergency
coveted funding
which we hadn't been expecting um kobe
does still hit us hard and it will hit
us hard next year as well
but actually the situation isn't as bad
now
as we thought it was going to be back in
the summer which led to the council
decision in september to
use three million pounds worth of
reserves some of this is explained in
the budget report and the medium-term
financial strategy reports
that went to cabinet and council in uh
in february
so i think we sort of have begun to see
that although we did
take a big hit during in-year because of
covet since then
things have improved a little bit and
that improvement we are holding within
our reserves
so we've got some flexibility entering
21 22 and beyond
to start releasing those reserves as
they are needed as we see
the impact of kovid play out in the in
the in the next couple of years
okay thank you for that it's really i
think council towny did you ever
yeah sorry sarah right
you might think i'm on your case or
something you know
it's not like that i promise you um
you've implemented a report on the port
of ramsgate
uh and this goes back quite a while do
you know when this report's going to be
concluded
um because you know the ramsgate poor
is a very important element for future
income and generating jobs and so on and
so forth for the area
um i just wondered where you are with
that report
um so my because my predecessor received
that objection my predecessor is uh
working through that
um i understand uh that he is in regular
contact
with chris and who's responding to our
information requests and i i understood
it nearing a conclusion um
i don't know whether chris you've got a
more up-to-date uh position on that
yes it is it is nearing conclusion but i
wouldn't want to uh
give a definitive answer at the moment
until it's it's uh
it's over the line
okay okay over the lines
sorry sarah yeah the auditor so my
colleague has to
finalize what the objection what our
conclusion on the objection is
so i think we're by it's very close to
reaching that point but there are a
number of because it's a statutory power
there's a number of statutory processes
to go through
um where we will issue a draft response
to the objector
and they have to have time to respond to
that so there is just a piece
um on that that i think that's the piece
that chris is referring to
forget forgive my ignorance you know um
just the other thing that i just want to
talk to you about is that 1920
years 19 and 20 um
you were you objections were raised
about non-disclosure
uh settlements that uh were made
now i appreciate that there is the idsc
uh and you have touched on this matter
where other
other other issues are being dealt with
and so on and so forth
however uh the isdc uh
the issc is is is in progress
i mean are you in communication with um
uh councillor saunders to see where we
are going
and how we are going to deal with these
these objections about the
non-disclosure uh matters
um so uh i have been in contact
with the external legal counsel that the
the council has used um and i'm very
happy to
meet with councillor saunders as as part
of
continuing that work um so we have had
enough we have had
updates on uh in principle
where that committee is going but
obviously not in detail
because um that is not something that i
would want
to be um i it's not something that yes
then law school would need to be
involved in this is your process you
need to be running
we need to allow you to run that process
and then
comment on it um so that is our that's
that's our position on it
and yeah thank you very much i'm sorry
to ask you all those questions
never be sorry for asking a question no
questions are good
yeah um that's great i mean i think that
covered what something else i wanted to
ask as well
so that's great um is
it i'll give everybody else another
chance if they want to ask
any further questions on that i shall
move on
i think the this report has
been presented to us for information
so chair technically you need to
consider
our findings on the audit before you ask
members to
vote on approving the statement of
account um so that's the that's the
technicality of it okay
all right so so we we need to consider
that and um
not approve it here
when you come to your item 10 it will be
about
exactly right getting a bit out of sync
there
thank you for the collaboration right so
we'll move we'll move on to
the um item nine on the
agenda which is the audit committee
assurance statement
which i'll ask again mr blundell to
introduce this
thank you thank you chair okay so in
terms of this
report and the statement um to comply
with auditing standards
the external external auditor so sarah
needs to establish an understanding of
the management processes in place
to detect fraud and ensure compliance
with laws and regulation
uh the external orders is also required
to make inquiries of management as to
our knowledge of any actual suspected or
alleged fraud
the external auditor also needs to gain
an understanding
of how this committee the governance and
audit committee remains
maintains an oversight of those above
processes
so these exact requirements are detailed
in a
letter from grant thornton in annex 1 to
this report
that was addressed to the previous
committee chair council of day
and then the response to those questions
set out in that letter is set out
in annex 2. so the response
was prepared by myself in consultation
with
uh yourself chair and also
the chief executive and estelle culligan
director of law and democracy however it
should be noted that its requirements
for the response to come from
the chair of the committee and not an
officer
and therefore the committee needs to be
assured that the information submitted
to
the external auditor is sufficiently
robust for
your pro purposes and
members are invited to comment on the
response if they so wish
thank you so thank you for that um do
any
do any members have have any comment or
question about that
um if not
then i do for this i do need a
proposer so i'll propose that we
approve that response from me and
i'll ask councillor dexter if you could
please um
second that yes um i'll second this
motion
mr chairman thank you unless i hear
any objection i'll take that as approved
right no objection thank you
so finally item 10
the statement of accounts and again i'm
gonna hand over to um
mr blundell this is the one we've been
looking forward to
there's indeed thank you chair yeah this
is the uh the show stopper
um so as kind of uh referred to
previously
this report alongside a couple of others
was
initially tabled at the meeting on the
25th of november for approval however
because of those
issues surrounding dreamland and the
accounting associated with they were
deferred
that deferral meant that the accounts
were not approved by the end of november
in accordance with the statutory
deadline
however it's important to sort of note
and stress that
in missing the november target date we
didn't break any
laws but we did have a requirement and
we met that to publish a statement on
our
website explaining why the accounts had
not been published
on time it should also be sort of noted
that tdc is not alone in this situation
um more than half of local authorities
have not been able to meet this deadline
particularly due to the uh the stresses
and requirements of having to undertake
uh the completion of the account and the
order of them remotely
due to the pandemic so turn into the
accounts themselves
those members you have seen there are
very lengthy
um i expect you found them complex and
possibly hard to understand in certain
parts
in fact sir tony redmond's in his review
he recommended the a number of ways for
local authority accounts to be
simplified and measures to improve their
accessibility and transparency and
that's something that
um the government is considering but
obviously won't be in place for
the accounts that you're looking at now
and for accounts that will be preparing
for
2021 i
certainly don't propose that we go
through all 150 pages of the accounts
uh we'll be here for a a little while
longer um the cover report
sets out some of the key messages i'll
just highlight those that's out on
section two the cover report
namely that when you look at our
comprehensive income and expenditure
statements that's equivalent to a profit
and loss account
for a private company it shows we had a
42 million pound net cost of services
um this included though a 19.5 million
pound valuation change due to dreamland
that we kind of referred to earlier
and almost all of that 42 million pound
net cost of services
they were adjusted out to non-usable
reserves and when i say non-usable
reserves
those are reserves are in place to
capture movement in the likes of
valuation of assets and liabilities such
as property and pensions
and other sort of timing issues that are
required due to statutory requirements
and as such they didn't actually have a
cash impact on our usable reserves
and we strip those adjustments out our
net usable reserves actually increased
by
678 000 pounds in a year to a gross
uh total of 48 million pounds
that 48 million sounds like quite a
significant figure when we've often
referring to how low our balance in the
reserves are
but it's only 13.5 million that relates
to the general fund reserves and
balances
which saw one million pound increase in
the year the rest of that 48 million is
actually
specifically attributed to the hra or
capital receipts
um continue just to focus on the general
fund as as tim
has already covered off today our
general fund reserves and balances are
low
relative to other authorities
and district councils of the like and
we've reported that position
uh previously it should also be noted
that that one million pound increases
is pre-covered and we are expecting to
as tim
has already said be taking money out
reserves this year
to um combat them um
what are some in terms of the
balance sheet itself um
we have sorry just lost my place on the
page
of my notes
the council's overall net worth
uh reduced during the year from 196
million pound to 178 million pound
um that was a decrease of 8 million that
was mainly as i was referred to earlier
due to the reclassification of dreamland
but in addition to that there was also
an increase in our pension liability
from uh to 90.4 million pound
but these are all issues that don't have
an immediate effect
on the council's financial position
so um members are asked to approve the
accounts
as has been reported in acts 1 and but
also note the letter of representation
um from management that is included at
annex 2. i'm happy to take any
questions on the accounts thank you
thanks very much for that i don't um
i don't have anyone wanting to ask a
question or make a comment at the moment
um so i shall thank you for that
for presenting them to us and move on to
propose that we do in fact approve the
statement account
and note the letter of representation
and
ask councillor dexter if he wouldn't
mind um
seconding that please
uh yes mr chairman i'll second that
motion
thank you thank you very much so unless
i hear any objection
i'll take that as approved
so that is approved thank you so
we we're coming towards the end of the
meeting there's no more items on the
agenda just before
concluding i'd just like to thank
everybody
for for attending the meeting this
evening and i'd especially like to thank
um the officers and
those from internal order and external
audit for
your work producing and presenting those
reports to us
so that concludes the business for
tonight's meeting
i'll declare the meeting now closed at 6
20 pm thank you again for all the views
for participating
and thanks to everybody who um watched
at home